bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans ce dernier set fit week-end de 2014
vous le savez en votre émission dédiée à
l'actualité culture loisirs et sports de
la semaine est évidemment de votre
week-end pendant 26 minutes et au cours
de cette édition nous parlerons de vos
vacances de fin d'année avec la
directrice d'yveline tourisme sylvie là
où naquit vous donnera tous les bons
plans à ne pas rater notamment pour les
enfants et évidemment tous vos
rendez-vous du week-end et de quoi
remplir votre agenda pour les deux
prochains jours mais tout d'abord place
aux idées de sorties et comme tous les
15 jours sylvie la ona la directrice
d'yveline tourisme est présente sur le
plateau du 7-8 week-end bonjour sylvie
merci d'être là alors cette fois-ci
évidemment al'approche de noël vous nous
vous allez nous dresser une sélection
d'activités pour les enfants pendant les
vacances de fin d'année et on va
commencer avec des ateliers créatifs
cuisine ou autres comtés et spectacles
tout d'abord au musée lambinet au musée
lambinet à versailles alors
effectivement à versailles sont proposés
des ateliers créatifs alors pour noël
l'atelier boules de noël
évidemment ça paraissait n'est pas très
long non non et puis pour la nouvelle
année l'atelier cartes de voeux et tout
ça à bages d'abbas de pliage de
coloriage de découpage donc tout ça au
musée lambinet pendant les vacances de
noël
en tout cas jusque jusqu'à la fin de
l'année s'étalent sur les deux semaines
des vacances alors outre évidemment le
le musée lambinet il va y avoir des
cours de cuisine aussi du côté de
versailles
c'est ça et ça s'appelle let's cook in
english il y en a pour tous les niveaux
d'anglais on va du primaire au collège
en passant par le lycée donc on peut
avoir des cours de cuisine seul pour les
enfants mais aussi on peut faire les
ateliers parents enfants avec diverses
recettes qui sont toujours des recettes
américaines qui vont
du hamburger en passant par le ginger
bread les petits gâteaux en forme de
bonhomme de pain d'épicés les cupcakes
de noël
enfin plein de choses le glaçage des des
gâteaux des choses très gai à faire en
famille ou entre enfants pour noël
de quoi évidemment les amateurs de
cuisine anglo saxon outre les cours de
cuisine évidemment vacances veut dire
ateliers et animations cette fois ci l
animation de noël au musée maurice denis
oui c'est ça alors des ateliers créatifs
au musée maurice denis à saint germain
en laye mais aussi des comptes il ya des
après midi avec des contes de noël sur
l'esprit du musée maurice denis où il ya
actuellement 1
une exposition sur les vitraux et donc
évidemment tous les ateliers graphiques
seront réalisés autour des vitraux et
puis on va apprendre parce que c'est
noël on va apprendre à faire des
guirlandes de fleurs et de fruits en
pochoir pour décorer les tables de noël
de quoi avoir évidemment une belle table
pour le réveillon on reste évidemment
dans l'esprit de noël et ce noël
féerique du côté de poissy alors c'est
au musée du jouet un quoi de plus adapté
que le musée du jouet quand on parle de
noël au musée du joyeux ras des comptes
effectivement des comptes sur il était
le père noël donc un conte autour du
père noël bien sûr et puis la petite
fille des neiges ou aussi qui est un
conte qui est inspiré d'une histoire
traditionnelle russe également des
ateliers autour de lanternes magiques et
puis bien sûr les petits trains les
petits trains miniatures de noël le
classique jouets de noël qu'on offre aux
petits garçons une époque
et puis pour finir une grande journée
exceptionnelle de magie le 28 le 28
décembre aussi au musée
du jouet à poissy et comment ne pas
parler de noël sans parler de la barge
heure initiale mais surtout de cette
crèche vivante
oui alors pendant toutes les vacances de
noël il y a des choses à faire à la
bergerie nationale donc bien sûr comme
vous venez de le dire c'est la crèche
vivante que l'on va voir puisque
bergerie égal à niveau égal crèche
vivante forcément c'était tout à fait
naturel et puis également comme c'est la
bergerie on peut mettre en place d'aidés
at on peut participer plutôt à des
ateliers qui sont basés autour des
produits de la bergerie et qui sont des
ateliers pour faire des décorations de
noël
il y a aussi un grand marché gourmand
qui est là et puis le père noël va venir
le 20 décembre il sera là donc la
bergerie nationale ne manquera pas de
vous étonner pendant toutes les vacances
de noël
rambouillet on parlait tout à l'heure de
compte il y a aussi des contes des
histoires du côté du château de
rambouillet toujours à rambouillet donc
des comptes des visites en famille
des ateliers des spectacles c'est au
château cette fois ci et c'est en fait
c'est dans le cadre de contes et
histoires qui se passent dans l'ensemble
des musées nationaux
donc c'est pas seulement au château de
rambouillet mais c'est aussi dans
d'autres musées nationaux par exemple à
la maison à la villa savoye à poissy
mais aussi à maisons-laffitte au château
et donc on va on va faire tout un tas de
d'ateliers on va avoir des comptes qui
vous seront racontées bien sûr et puis
il ya aussi des fêtes galantes alors ça
c'est assez extraordinaire parce que ça
ne se voit pas tous les jours c'est les
fêtes du xviiie siècle qui sont
reproduites au château de rambouillet et
également par voie de conséquence on met
en place on les a mis en place des
ateliers sur les costumes qui sont
utilisés c'est que ces costumes du
xviiie siècle qui sont utilisés à
l'occasion des fêtes galantes
donc c'est vraiment extrêmement
diversifié c'est ces fêtes de noël au
château de rambouillet oui les fêtes
galantes 1 pour le ne pas les rater
c'est les 20 et 21 décembre donc ce
week-end pour pouvoir voir ses costumes
d'époque et enfin pour les plus sportifs
et ceux qui veulent prendre l'air les
patinoires travail
un événement du mois de décembre alors
chaque année vous savez que je vous
dresse la liste des patinoires des
yvelines mais la liste est de plus en
plus longues
il y en a de plus en plus de plus en
plus performantes elles sont souvent
écologique ces cas de la patinoire de
versailles qui est chaque année sur la
place de l'hôtel de ville donc celle là
et écologique
vous avez également une patinoire aux
mureaux qui est une grande patinoire de
300 mètres carrés où il ya les moins de
2 ans fallait les deux ans qui peuvent
venir
vous avez une patinoire opéré en
yvelines qui ce qui est organisé dans
plein centre ville dans le village de
noël à sartrouville également une grande
patinoire au à buchelay buchelay et à
rambouillet et et puis également à
trappes dans le cap de la féerie de
trappes une grande patinoire donc si on
a envie de patiner ou peut faire le tour
du département à patins à glace dans
l'ensemble des patinoires
merci beaucoup si lui pour toutes ces
idées de sorties pendant ces fêtes de
fin d'année on retrouve évidemment en
2015 pour la rendre le nouveau plan et
idées de sorties merci beaucoup merci
une autre année date pardon à notre
agenda loisirs at on retenir pour ce
week-end cette année-là l'office de
tourisme de saint quentin en yvelines
vous fait découvrir le territoire saint
quentinois sous la neige avec le scrap
booking
dans un décor et une ambiance créée pour
l'occasion les plus jeunes pourront
participer à des ateliers créatifs
encadré et animé par lily pot de colle
sur le thème de noël vous l'avez compris
cartes et mini albums sont au programme
ateliers gratuits
je précise sur réservation auprès de
l'office de tourisme
on enchaîne avec la suite et le sapin de
noël évidemment
150 millions d'euros c'est ce que
représente le marché du sapin de noël
naturel chaque année et qu'il s'agisse
de l'épicéa ou du nordmann les français
ne semblent pas prêts à sacrifier cette
tradition bien ancrée et malgré la crise
reportage chez un sylviculteur de la
région avec wilfrid rifi et patrick jacq
de victimes
quelques clients viennent encore
chercher le sapin au pied duquel le père
noël déposera la semaine prochaine c'est
cadeau pour ce sylviculteur de la vallée
de chevreuse le mois de décembre n'a pas
été aussi mauvais que prévu sur le plan
des recettes
le panier moyen se situe entre 30 et 40
euros les français ne semblent pas prêts
à faire des sacrifices manière la crise
c'est un symbole c'est quelque chose qui
est qui qui marque les fêtes de fin
d'année les nouvelles forcément un petit
peu de magie dans la maison que nagy un
peu d'odeur c'est sa gamme un peu de
verdure
la romance est un peu triste le dernier
week end avant noël devrait permettre
d'écouler les derniers modèles dispersés
sur ces quelques 2000 mètres carrés
il faudra néanmoins que les conditions
climatiques le permettent le mauvais
temps principales difficultés
rencontrées cette année
malheureusement cette année il disait
que c'est l'année la plus chaude depuis
1900 donc mal aurait en plus elle est
très très humide là aujourd'hui encore
on a de la chance il pleut pas mais les
gens ils choisissent pas pareil faudra
que ça vienne tous les ans comme ça
parce que c'est vrai que on a aussi avec
la conjoncture actuelle on a besoin de
sous et voilà à quoi donc si ça sera un
peu moins bon que l'année dernière mais
enfin bon
l'an dernier un foyer sur quatre avec
installer un sapin pour noël
en revanche c'est du côté des mairies
que l'on fait des économies dans cette
sapinière on a d'ailleurs arrêté de
produire des grands modèles de 12 m
souvent installés en centre ville
faute de demande on enchaîne avec notre
page exposition
six artistes contemporains vous invite
en ce moment à une exposition autour du
thème résonance à la ferme du mousseau à
elancourt photographies peintures
sculptures et même film évoque la
mémoire du corps et de ses perceptions
catherine mulato et elodie mois
projeter ses propres émotions à travers
des oeuvres très diverses présentée à la
galerie de la ferme du mousseau à
elancourt vidéo gravures peintures
sculptures la matière est certes
différentes mais le message est unique
ses oeuvres sont en résonance le titre
de l'exposition
cette année cette exposition a comme
volonté que différents artistes
répondent à faire leur oeuvre
au-delà de l'aspect résonance des
oeuvres se raisonne aussi bien le mal et
le bien le blanc le gris le noir et le
blanc est donc on est capable de montrer
c'est ce que l'on veut ici que l'art
n'exprime pas seulement que le plaisir
et le bonheur
il exprime aussi des drames il exprime
aussi parce que ça fait partie de la vie
la mort dans ce cadre là nous avons des
artistes qui nous ont proposé des corps
mutilés
mais des corps mutilés comme un espoir
pour la suite
c'est six artistes ont été choisis après
une sélection vient jury une centaine de
dossiers a été reçu cette année parmi
eux
thibault la géraud 38 ans son atelier
dans les yvelines
ses grandes toiles colorées raconte des
histoires d'aujourd'hui
l'idée c'est de l'inspirer 2
d'image de photo reporters qui ont
traité de sujets que ça soit beaucoup
sur le thème de la liberté
donc j'ai beaucoup travaillé sur le
printemps arabe la syrie
je m'inspire de plutôt de récits et
j'essaye à travers les récits écrits et
les photos qui ont été prises par les
juges du photo reporter de compiler en
fait sur une toile multitude de
sentiments et en fait d'histoire
l'actualité c'est donc le nerf de la
guerre pour cet artiste et les couleurs
chatoyantes pour mieux masquer la
noirceur des récits sur la couleur je
dirais que c'est venu petit à petit le
départ schrei avec relativement peu de
couleurs très chromatique des couleurs
complémentaires 3 4 maximum et puis plus
ça va plus les sujets sont compétitifs
et plus j'en rajoute plus le sujet
dramatique plus aujourd'hui je vais
mener à faire des
dick toile extrêmement colorés comme une
sorte d' équilibre entre le sujet de
fond et la forme
l'exposition résonances se tient
jusqu'au 21 décembre à la galerie de la
ferme du mousseau à elancourt
comédiens musiciens et bruiteur il y a
quelques jours notre chroniqueur de
l'émission que ce que nicolas gervais
vous présenter l'intégrale de la
cordonnerie qui sera sur scène jusqu'au
22 décembre au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
madame voilà bientôt trois jours que
votre jeune fille ce n'est point sorti
de sa chambre
je ne peux en 97 et pas loin de 20 ans
et donc on était très jeune à l'époque
et ça s'appelle la cordonnerie parce que
les premières les premiers spectacles
les premières répétitions avaient lieu
dans l'arrière boutique d'une
cordonnerie
c'est la directrice du théâtre de
vénissieux donc c'est en banlieue de
lyon qui est venu nous voir dans un café
qui nous a dit marc venez dans mon
théâtre et les spectacles vous présentez
peut-être qu'il pourrait en fait bien
correspondre au spectacle jeune public
est donc là avec méthyle on a commencé à
travailler notamment autour des contes
vous me reconnaissez parfaitement un
maquereau non non mon seigneur je suis
très bien ici
oui mon seigneur qu'elle marche à
l'ombre
un ciné spectacles enfin bon qu'on a
inventé
donc il ya du cinéma terrain film en
l'occurrence il est muet mais un film
dans une facture tout à fait moderne qui
est l'adaptation en fait filmer don d'un
compte on a avant dapd écrit un scénario
et après sur scène en scène muel mois
avec deux musiciens dont timothée joly
qui fait là la composition musicale
on est quatre sur scène et on met en
musique en voit les images que vous
voyez derrière nous qui est très
spécifique c'est qu'on réalise nous
mêmes le film donc on joue dans ce film
et on nous retrouve également sur scène
donc sur scène on réinterprète en direct
les dialogues du film en cause synchro
ont raconté que victor frankenstein
organisé des combats de boxe entre des
lilliputiens gré à son image
on raconte également qu'il aimait dîner
aux chandelles avec lui-même à chaque
réveillon un chasseur affirmé même avoir
vu le docteur frankenstein jongler avec
certes est dans une forêt près du manoir
et on reste dans les spectacles mais
cette fois-ci musicaux et au prisme
d'elancourt ce samedi soir vous pourrez
voir du jazz au féminin avec eva selon
gautriaud c'est donc un trio composé
d'un ordre d'une batterie et d'un violon
autour de la violoniste suisse et va
selon go formé notamment par didier le
coup de tarifs à partir de 9 euros je
vous propose d'écouter un petit extrait
m
et on enchaîne avec un grand classique à
présent pour ce week-end le carnaval des
animaux de camille saint saëns une vraie
fantaisie zoologique à tarif à partir de
3 euros rendez vous à la ferme de bel
ébat de guyancourt ce samedi à 18 heures
on est con est un extrait et je pense
que ça va vous rappeler quelques
souvenirs
on
on enchaîne avec le sport et vous le
savez le club de handball de montigny le
bretonneux est un club reconnu pour sa
formation chez les jeunes dans le
département et au sein de l'équipe moins
de 18 ans filles les qualités de cinq
joueuses ont été repérés par les pôles
espoirs français dont 3 vive la semaine
à orléans immersion dans un quotidien
100% en mal réalisé avec patrick jacques
de dixmude
elles suivent les cours comme tous les
jeunes lycéens de l'orage pourtant sarah
à nay aminata partagent leur quotidien
entre l'école et les terrains de
handball issus du club de montigny le
bretonneux
ces trois jeunes filles ont intégré au
début de l'année scolaire le pôle espoir
d'orléans
tout juste âgé de 15 ans elles ont dû
s'adapter à cette nouvelle vie 100%
balle loin des amis d'enfance loin de la
famille réussit un peu d'hier matin
j'habitais dans ça c'est difficile
puisqu'il ya l'éloignement avec la
famille et c'est vrai beaucoup de choses
sont mis en place pour elle donc quand
elle se rend pour les sports c'est c'est
relativement aisé d'être en pôle espoir
puisque tout est mis en place lundi soir
il ya une psychologue qui vient tous les
lundis soirs pour les accompagner il ya
un kinésithérapeute que présent le lundi
et le jeudi soir un médecin le jeudi
soir donc il ya vraiment un cocon qui
est mis autour d'elle nour les suivent
également dans leur double projet au
niveau scolaire si ça fonctionne pas
qu'est-ce qui se passe voilà on met en
place des aménagements auxquels sont
vraiment suivi encadré anna c'est un
petit peu la belle histoire de cette
promotion
d'abord refusé elle est arrivée fin
septembre pour remplacer le départ d'une
autre joueuse après de rentrée scolaire
et quelques semaines d'adaptation
elle met les bouchées doubles pour se
mettre à niveau a salué des prix c'est
une motivation ça veut dire que chez
nous et donc ou alors qu'on veut
apporter d'autres choses pour que m'ont
hélas oui jusqu'où ils peuvent donc oui
c'est une motivation puis je m'investis
geste m'investir au minois travail
combativité et mental c'est par là que
les inhumant ten s'ouvriront les portes
des centres de formation pour certaines
inspiré par des grands joueurs comme luc
abalo leurs ambitions sont claires
atteindre le haut niveau tout en gardant
les pieds sur terre et l'esprit à
l'école est bien l'un des revers
je crie haut niveau pourquoi c'est
important thème de continuer l'école
pour quelle raison parce que l'anti
jamais je me blesse ou seven sécurité
donc que sharon en cours par dose de 12
heures par semaine au pôle les jeune
femme enchaîne les entraînements en
moyenne deux par jour sans compter la
session du vendredi soir avec leur club
de montigny et le match du week-end a
même exigence pour tous à toutes au même
niveau vraiment qu'une tige ou le
week-end qui est sur le juin -18 c'est
la gardienne inna défis qui peuvent être
meilleures que d'autres qui sont par
paul parce que s'ils sont en formation
en france 24 pôle espoir nourrissent les
10 centres de formation des clubs
professionnels
on passe à votre agenda sport du
week-end et surtout le match à ne pas
rater ce samedi soir c'est du basket
128e de la coupe de france maurepas
pensionnaires d'excellence en niveau
départemental va recevoir l'ogre
barjouville club qui évolue en nationale
3 autant dire que ce sera un match
opposant david contre goliath ce
week-end au gymnase de la malle me donne
si vous voulez aller supporter les mort
passe bien n'hésitez pas à vous habiller
en rouge les couleurs du club
coup d'envoi à 20h ce samedi soir on
enchaîne avec notre page de cinéma
et notre traditionnel coup d'oeil sur
les salles obscures du week-end cette
semaine c'est cyril à date des
clayes-sous-bois de l'espace philippe
noiret qui vous délivre son coup de
coeur cette semaine notre coup de coeur
et le film français le père noël réalisé
par alexandre coffre avec tahar rahim
en cette nuit de noël antoine 6 ans n'a
qu'une idée en tête rencontrer le père
noël et faire un tour de traîneau avec
lui dans les étoiles
alors quand celui-ci ton par magie de
son balcon antoine est trop émerveillé
pourvoir ans ce père noël un
cambrioleurs déguisés qui des robes
bijoux dans les appartements des bocar 6
et malgré tous les efforts du père noël
pour se débarrasser d'un antoine
déterminés ils vont former alors 1-0
invraisemblable parcourant paris le toit
en toit chacun à la recherche de son
rêve
le père noël est un vent de fraîcheur
insufflé par un duo magique tarime
impeccable en père noël cambrioleurs et
victor kabel garçonnet au naturel
désarmant et un poil malicieux le
spectateur se laissera emporter par
cette jolie histoire pleine d'humour et
de fantaisie
le père noël et la comédie de saison qui
enchantera et touchera toutes les
générations
on en sortira et ce film est un bon
divertissement à découvrir en cette fin
d'année à l'espace philippe noiret
classement
le pape avec le tpiy
quelque chose paille d'or pour manger
reste focus et si vous ne savez pas quel
film aller voir pendant les vacances de
fin d'année voici quelques idées de
spectateurs au micro d' elodie mois il
est sympa c'est un peu différent de
madagascar mais
voilà il y avait tout il y avait
l'action il y avait de l'humour je
trouve qu'elle est pas mal
j'ai bien aimé ça me rappelle les bandes
dessinées ma jeunesse je pense que c'est
plus un film pour enfants que pour
analyse après vingt ans en fait un écart
entre son prédécesseur je trouvais que
pas que les acteurs ils sont toujours
aussi impliqué dans le monde donc je
trouve moi j'ai passé un bon moment
je trouvais que il n'avait rien perdu de
leur superbe très bien très bon film
authentique et puis une bonne suite oui
joue à fond la carte de la nostalgie
puis on a l'impression qu'ils ont pas
dit exactement mon cas ça fait toujours
plaisir
c'est un film magnifique que je vais
revoir une deuxième fois fola
j'ai bien aimé j'ai trouvé très émouvant
et drôle à la fois l'humour caustique du
prof de chant etc
j'adorais voilà un film qui réconcilie
avec la famille simplement et puis non
vraiment j'ai trouvé ça
très divertissant et puis très
attendrissant souk c'est la fin de cette
édition merci encore une fois de l'avoir
suivi je vous souhaite un excellent
week-end est passé de très bonnes fêtes
de fin d'année